working hard and autoimmune diseases
often don't coexist and they hate each
other I've been type 1 diabetic for 22
years now so you know eight injections a
day trying to deal with maintaining my
blood sugar levels having a life working
in recruitment managing a team I know
that there's been clients in the past
that I've last minute had to cancel on
and they're pissed off at me and I just
think God it's hard enough you know
going through all of this and feeling
this poorly and feeling this incapable
and you've got people you know on the
other end that aren't being
understanding and it's really
self-deprecating and I've had a lot of
low moments where I've just felt like oh
my God can I physically do this it could
be really debilitating and I think again
that's why I share a lot of what I go
through on LinkedIn because I don't want
people to feel alone and people that
can't always put in 100 and sharing
these stories is where it begins and if
I can make it seem more normal and more
spoken about then that's a great place
to start
[Music]